Thundercats ranks among the best
cartoons of the 80s alongside the likes
of masters of the universe and
transformers you may not have noticed at
the time but Thundercats has some truly
unusual touches that read very
differently to adult eyes
[Applause]
Thundercats is a bit of a sweeping epic
and it all begins with an off forgotten
origin story the Thundercats have to
leave their doomed home planet of
thundera and at the time lion-o is just
a young boy
they're also mostly underdressed by the
way but that changes quickly because of
a long journey ahead of them the cats
have to spend time and suspended
animation on the way to their new home
when they arrive on Third Earth young
lion-o finds that his body has grown
into that of a muscular adult man but
his mind is the same why I'm grown even
though the original team includes three
actual adults lion-o is still the team
leader because he's a hereditary lord of
the Thundercats early on
lion-o's immaturity and the Eve of T is
a story point but before long that
aspect mostly falls by the wayside there
are plenty of moments when lion-o's
behavior makes more sense when you
remember that he's just an enormous kid
but it's almost never made explicit
after the first episode a fine figure of
a Thundercat you've grown up to be
lion-o and so handsome to a thundera
falls apart during the show's premier
the central thundercats escaped the
destruction under the leadership of
their wise old leader Jagger Jagger
doesn't live to see their new home on
Third Earth but he frequently returns as
a shimmering blue ghost no specific
explanation for the destruction of
thundera is given in that first episode
it's only much later in the third season
episode thundercubs that we learn the
reason for the entire planet falling
apart and it's all Jagger's fault years
earlier when jaga was a much younger man
cats he defeated a mutants leader named
Drusilla he would carried a double
bladed magical weapon the sword of
plun-darr which is basically the evil
equivalent to the Thundercats own sword
of omens
upon defeating Rotella jaga through the
sword of plun-darr into a volcanic
canyon in order to destroy it however he
underestimated the swords evil magic and
the sword of plun-darr works its way to
the core of thundera splitting the
planets apart surprisingly little is
made of the fact that the wise advisor
who was guided the Thundercats all this
time actually made the mistake that cost
them everything
Thundercats largely takes place on a
planet called further
the back can't possibly be our earth
right it just looks too weird
we live on first earth or as we call it
earth
the third one must be out in space
somewhere however if you pay attention
the show makes clear that third is a
matter of time not space this is Earth
in its third age when humans are no
longer the dominant species and many of
the planet's inhabitants are alien
colonists and refugees from across the
cosmos the fact is made especially clear
in the episode Excalibur
when Merlin makes a guest appearance and
reveals that the King Arthur stories
took place on the same planet where the
Thundercats now live Merlin isn't the
only ancient immortal who survived from
first earth to third the show's main
villain mumra2k Tagore II with his
glowing red eyes deathly gray pallor and
twisted face mumm-ra's terrifying as 80s
cartoon villains go which is all the
more reason that it's not entirely
obvious that he's the only human being
in the main cast of Thundercats at least
mummer I used to be a human being he's
an ancient Egyptian sorcerer who was
granted immortality by his gods who he
calls the ancient spirits of evil
Egyptian history is avoided on
Thundercats but it's hard to miss them
Umbra is a mummy who lives in a pyramid
and the ancient spirits of evil of human
bodies and animal heads just like many
gods of Egyptian mythology
mumm-ra's name is a portmanteau of mummy
and the Egyptian Sun God raah so while
the Thundercats arrived from thundera
and the mutants come from the planet
plunder and even the burbles arrived
from Third Earth in a spaceship
mumm-ra's has been here all along of all
the Thundercats characters he's the one
with whom we share DNA and he's not
completely wrong about being upset of
the invasion of his planet early on the
powers of the Thundercats mystical sword
of omens seems pretty clear it magically
extends from dagger length into a full
sword it casts a big red cat signal into
the sky to some of the other Thundercats
it shoots energy beams and they allows
lion-o to see across great distances
site via
as the series goes on however a sword of
omens has whatever powers it needs to
have to resolve our particular plots
they can project both fire and ice at
various moments can project solid
objects like walls and bridges it flies
and even allows its bearer to fly
whenever that's convenient it even
prevents the Thundercats home planet
from exploding for a second time a
magical sword with many uses is fine but
as an adult viewer it's pretty clear
that the writers would just give the
sword of omens at new power anytime they
wrote themselves into a corner for most
of the series snarf is just another in a
long line of annoying little squeaky
voice characters who don't fit in there
shows a lineage stretching from
scrappy-doo to Orko to screech but snarf
once had a very specific job acting as
lion-o's nanny or something gets the
blame when lion-o was a kid snarf was
employed to watch over him and keep him
safe once he has an adult body lion-o
tells snarf he doesn't need that anymore
even though he's become even more prone
to getting into trouble than ever before
and snarf entire existence is pretty
much rendered pointless
snarf as a chronic warrior which makes
him suited to babysitting but when he
doesn't have that job anymore the same
quality is what makes him incredibly
annoying check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
you
[Music]